[Musique]
c'est l'heure de quoi c'est l'heure de
qui c'est l'heure de la Guinguette ah
oui parce que c'est
beau on fait la fête et oui je vous
invite à la Guinguette de Tours sur
Loire l'endroit respire la tranquillité
et la détente ceux qui reflète bien
l'état d'esprit des tours enjeux et tout
en gel et oui parce qu'il se passe
toujours quelque chose à la Guinguette
et la Guinguette et oui c'est bon on
fait la fête et aujourd'hui par exemple
il y a l'association Bunny Boli intour
qui donne des cours de danse
bollywoodienne d'ailleurs je vais
m'initier à quelque part et m'incruster
dans les spectacle mais pour l'instant
rencontre avec Laetitia l'une des
responsables de la Guinguette la
Guinguette et Toulon
[Musique]
c'est la Guinguette la Guinguette la
Guinguette on fait un fait Laetitia BIM
qui est le sourire qu'elle smile c'est
quoi c'est la Guinguette qui rend comme
ça c'est la loi tu me rejoins tu viens
en tout cas il y a une super ambiance
c'est comme ça tous les soirs à partir
du mois de mai jusque
fin septembre
on était installés dans une forêt on est
organisé notre premier festival qui
durait déjà 4 mois et puis l'Amérique
qui décide de faire revivre les quais et
et là ça marche tout de suite c'était
beaucoup plus petit ça a grandi en 20
ans
alors ici on est à la Guinguette qu'on
appelle la Guinguette centrale où la
principale avec son plancher danse la
scène et le restaurant chez ta mère
les parents peuvent boire l'apéro
pendant que les enfants jouent comme le
chanteur délai mais FAO comment ça fait
plaisir
[Musique]
incontournable il y a des loups aussi ça
va les loups la forme tranquille
[Musique]
de danse Bollywood tous les jeudis il y
a un apéro dance tu peux prendre des
cours de danse c'est libre tu viens en
famille tu te fais plaisir tu apprends à
danser exactement tous les vendredis il
y a des concerts plutôt scenes locales
les samedis plus grosses formes
spectacle ou gros concert ou soirée
thématique c'est un endroit vraiment
reconnu et apprécié par les tours enjeux
étrangères tous les âges moi depuis que
je suis là j'ai vu tous les âges
tous les milieux tout le monde se
mélange depuis toujours franchement la
musique là ça commence à me démanger
il y a le Bollywood qui rentre dans mon
corps je vais danser bon allez les gars
tenu Bollywood vous allez voir
métamorphose
[Musique]
ne suivez pas mes mouvements d'accord
c'est moi qui vous suis OK
[Musique]
bravo bravo bravo le trou bravo bravo